boris cyrulnik merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation s'te plaît d'être avec
vous au québec on vient de vivre une
année tellement particulière vous
comment vous traverser cette période de
manière honteusement agréable taba tant
mieux parce que j'ai la chance de faire
partie des privilégiés qui ont une
maison avec un avec un jardin au bord de
la mer et j'en ai profité pour bien
travailler parce que j'ai été empêchés
de voyager dont j'ai mieux travailler
justement depuis le début notre émission
on a vu des vies qui ont été
complètement bouleversée des changements
de carrière
certains réussissent à s'adapter plus
facilement pourquoi certains parmi nous
avant le confinement avaient acquis des
factures de protection que c'est à dire
il parlait bien
il avait une famille stable il avait mis
un diplôme suffisant pour avoir un
métier convenable donc il avait un grand
logement
et quand le virus a imposé le
confinement
ils n'ont pas souffert et après le virus
ils vont redémarrer sans traumatisme
al'inverse ceux qui avant le virus avait
acquis des facteurs de vulnérabilité
famille instable maladie accidents de la
vie surpopulation dans un petit logement
ils vont se retrouver dans trente mètres
carrés avec à six personnes
donc harceler exaspéré ceux là vont
revivre le confinement comme un
traumatisme et après la sortie du
confinement si on les entoure pas dure
pas beaucoup de processus de résilience
peut-être l'espoir est en train de
revenir avec les vaccins mais en même
temps on sent une très grande fatigue
c'est comme si l'incertitude nous pesait
alors est ce que c'est ça qui cause
notre anxiété parce que parce qu'on sait
pas comment tout ça va se terminer et
quand ça va se terminer
on a une usure de l'âme tout le monde a
un peu marre on voudrait que ce soit
fini
le vaccin va nous donner un plan
d'action délestant ona plan d'action
même si on souffre en affronte en
revanche quand on n'a pas de plan
d'action consommons part dans tous les
sens donc c'est quoi c'est donc la
souffrance est aggravée par
l'incertitude et ça c'est dangereux
pour la sortie du virus c'est que chaque
fois qu'il ya un moment de chaos social
on constate que les gens qui survivent
dans la certitude soient anxieux parce
qu'ils savent pas quoi faire
ça va faire comment se défendre et que
arrive toujours très souvent un sauveur
qui sécurise les gens en leur disant moi
j'ai la solution voté pour moi et c'est
comme ça qu'un grand nombre de
dictateurs sont régulièrement élu
démocratiquement après des périodes de
chaos social
on vous sent un peu inquiet quand même
pour la suite alors eh oui le virus sur
le plan biologique c'est rien c'est 12
gel encapsulé dans une un petit sac de
lipides sais rien tout le reste est un
processus de civilisation s'est créée
par la civilisation dont outreau2
d'élevage d'animaux à manger
déforestation massacre du sol mélangent
des excréments des animaux fabrication
c'est nous qui fabriquons le virus y en
a plein dans la nature de virus mais
c'est nous ensuite qui les transportait
d'abord on les a transportés avec les
caravanes de chameaux la route de la
soie
et puis ensuite c'est les avions qui
sont les nouveaux chameaux et qui
transporte les les tissus qui
transportent les aliments avec les
bactéries et avec les virus
doumé épiler me répéter il va falloir
changer on pourra pas reprendre notre
vie comme elle était avant
alors il ya des gens qui proposent de
reprendre la vie comme elle était avant
il ya même des gens des économistes
surtout qu'ils proposent de rattraper le
retard
donc si on remet en place les processus
qui ont fabriqué le virus et qui l'ont
transporté eh bien on va faire une
nouveau siècle des pestes et dans trois
ans il y aura un nouveau virus avec une
autre formule chimique il faudra tout
recommencer
comment tenir alors avec tout avec
toutes ses mesures sanitaires avec le
couvre-feu notre vie sociale qui est
tellement tellement limité et depuis
maintenant un an que ça dure
à quel point ça aussi c'est compliqué
pour un être humain
bien sûr si le très grave le confinement
qui
qui nous protège du virus nous agressent
neurologiquement et psychologiquement
isolement sensoriel provoque des
altérations cérébrales
le bébé même s'il est un peu altérée si
sa mère est sécurisé elle deviendra
sécurisante pour le bébé qu'elle porte
dans son ventre ou dans ses bras si les
personnes âgées sont isolés c'est très
grave
là une personne âgée en isolement
sensoriel
elle se lève partie on appelle ça le
syndrome du glissement elle cesse de
manger fs de bois et elmer n'ont pas de
déshydratation mais de carences
affectives parce qu'elle se laisse
partir et la partie dangereuse de la
population c'est les adolescents les
adolescents sont une période sensible de
leur développement
c'est le moment où ils prennent leur
trajectoire affective c'est le moment
des grandes rencontres
il ya déjà un an perdu quand il vient
déjà beaucoup de décrochages comment ils
vont faire pour se relancer certains
bien sûr pour se relancer ce qui avait
un bon entourage mais beaucoup vont
casser parler des personnes âgées
justement elles ont payé un prix très
lourd dans cette pandémie
alors pour elle est-ce que les séquelles
vont être durable le cerveau des
personnes vers j'ai beaucoup moins
plastique que celui des jeunes les
personnes âgées n'ont plus la même forme
de résilience c'est à dire que eux pour
se remettre à vivre il leur suffit de
peu un coup de téléphone de temps en
temps est visible dans un point et la
possibilité de vivre dans leur mémoire
avec des photos donc le processus de
résilience sera facile parce que les
personnes âgées au moins de deux bornes
moins d'exigences mais si on fait pas ça
dure beaucoup de morts beaucoup de
familles ont pas pu accompagner leur
prochain dans les derniers jours pendant
la première vague ou même faire des
rituels de deuil ça aussi c'est un
traumatisme annonce alors c'est un
traumatisme pour les enfants pour les
survivants
ça c'est la culpabilité pathologique que
beaucoup de gens ont déjà je n'ai rien
fait je le même pas dit adieu
il est mort mon père tout seul et alors
quand c'est très embêtant parce que
toutes les cultures ont inventé des
rituels du deuil apple seule culture
sans rituel du deuil et ses rituels du
deuil confie sa respecter le mort et à
redonner leur dignité aux vivants j'ai
fait ce qu'il fallait
je lui dis à dieu j'ai fait ce qu'il
fallait et là c'est pas possible se
culpabiliser photo agressent et très
souvent ils ont des comportements des
chèques
une dernière question pour vous mais
elle est là je sais pas si on peut
répondre comme ça mais se cerner comment
donner un sens à tout ce qui nous est
arrivé
c'est la question fondamentale c'est que
si on donne sens à ce qui nous arrive on
supporte rang ce qui vous arrive et si
on ne donne pas sauf on va déprimer
parce que ça allait être une souffrance
absurde
alors question d'un sens si on se dit
d'accord on a réuni notre pays d'accord
on a perdu un an
d'accord on s'est beaucoup ennuyé mais
en échange on va mettre en place une
manière de vivre ensemble qui sera plus
belle et plus harmonieuse donc ça valait
la peine de souffrir et à ce moment là
notre souffrance prend sens ça valait la
peine de souffrir parce que après on va
déclencher un processus de résilience
affectives culturelles et on vivra mieux
ça valait la peine de souffrir
j'espère qu'on dira cette phrase dans
quelques mois on l'espère tous monsieur
sérénac merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
notre invitation c'est un plaisir de
vous parler c'est un plaisir de parler
avec vous